how many military bases
foreign military bases do you think the
u.s has
i'm going to take a wild guess i'm going
to say 45. 45. folks if you're listen
how many military bases
do you think the u.s has foreign okay
kai you know this number sam do you know
this number how many military bases
do you think there are foreign u.s
military foreign you said 45
i'm going with that what do you think
the number is how many u.s
foreign military bases folks if you
think you know the answer comment below
you will also be shocked here in a
minute how many 50
51 what do you think foreign military
bases
oh i'll go with 55. 55 what are you
going to spend with she's good
800 whoa in 71 countries
now here's a trick question to everybody
you ready everybody's putting you
somebody put a thousand who put a
thousand greatest ever put a thousand
mark bucci put 350. chicken diner 13 put
800 he probably
searched it but you know that's a good
guess as well if you got it right aratus
i've solely put
60 trillion okay so let's go over here
i'm glad to hear that it's a high number
this one tom so blow your mind bro us
if the us has 800 military bases in 71
countries
how many military bases foreign military
bases do you think china has
how many think china has oh god i want
you to actually guess this
i want to i want to guess it's fewer i
want to say 300.
okay what do you think it is you guys
want to take a wild guess let me put it
through this but i guarantee you're not
going to get it right
i'm trying to help you here yeah so you
got to give a crazy number
fifteen hundred okay two thousand okay
one they have one they only have one i
knew it was
can you pull up the only foreign
military base china has and where it's
at folks this is like apps
people people can't even comment on this
stuff it's mind-blowing when you think
about this
china foreign military bases okay go to
where it's at
okay the djibouti is what it's called
exactly it's it's like yeah they like
djibouti that's exactly what it is can
you go to the military
where djiboutian so people can't award
your buddhists go to maps okay just go
to maps go to djibouti right there
it is the only foreign military base in
the chokehold
of the suez canal that is the only
military base china has now here's
another trick question for you
you ready yeah
okay by the way you and i were doing
poorly i just so happened to have gotten
this research because i would have never
guessed these numbers right here's the
next one
combine russia okay russia france
and britain okay okay three of the
powers in the world
how many military bases do they have
foreign between russia
france and britain do you know this i
don't know okay so you can guess on this
one how many do they have
i'm gonna guess this is not china so
this is a different number i just want
everybody to know this combine
combine combine all coming together i'm
gonna say it's a very low number
dominated by russia i'm gonna say 16.
okay what do you think it is
i'm going with a niner 90 nine
niner okay nine what do you guys say uh
i'm gonna say
five five okay china through everybody
it's actually 30. 30. it's actually 30.
those combined together you have 30.
are you not blown away by this this is
absolutely you saying
less is everywhere us is controversial
800 million
policing the world that's why but you're
paying for exactly but you're paying now
that's the question
and i'm a military i'm a pro military
guy i'm an army guy
is that a good thing or a bad thing
there's that many military bases here's
what's the point you know what happens
when you're involved in too many uh
people's
marital problems you know you know once
i become an enemy eventually
that's person right you know like those
moms that are too over controlled
how's this going how's that going
eventually mom just stay the hell out of
it you know
u.s is starting to become a little bit
too 800
foreign military bases 800 it's a lot
it's incomprehensible you know watch
what china is doing so china they have
one
specifically one why intentionally
because they want to make sure they're
getting their oil because most of the
oil comes from there so they need that
part right
but do you know what they're doing with
the other money u.s is spending fighting
wars the old-school way from the 56
70s all they're doing is bio
cyber hack they're studying all of those
ways and they're using those resources
so take creating
viruses doing their thing fauci said it
could be possible
apparently fauci my apologies
she said it could be john calls him fast
he goes so the point is so the point is
so that's one area
when you when you link military bases
and taxes
they actually go together so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye